la carga eléctrica q es una propiedad
que tienen algunas pero no todas las
partículas en la naturaleza las
partículas fundamentales cargadas de las
que más comúnmente se hablan son los
electrones los cuales orbitan al
exterior del átomo estos electrones
están cargados negativamente también por
acá tenemos a los protones los cuales
tienen una carga positiva y también
tenemos al 2 neutrones los cuales tienen
una carga neutra no son positivos ni
negativos no tienen carga alguna y tanto
los protones como los neutrones están
dentro del núcleo del átomo y resulta
que todas las partículas
fundamentalmente cargadas en el universo
tienen cargas que vienen en unidades
enteras de esta carga elemental así que
si encuentras una partícula en la
naturaleza va a tener la carga de uno
por este número o dos por este número o
tres por este número
etcétera y bueno podría ser positiva o
negativa por ejemplo el electrón tiene
una carga de menos 1.6 por 10 a la menos
19 con la oms el protón tiene una carga
de más 1.6 por 10 a las 19 con la oms
etcétera sin embargo la mayoría de los
átomos son eléctricamente neutros eso
quiere decir que tendrán tantos
electrones como protones en el átomo
pero si un átomo tuviera demasiados
electrones en general ese átomo estaría
cargado negativamente y si un átomo
tuviera muy pocos electrones en general
ese átomo estaría cargado positivamente
algo que es realmente importante
recordar es que la carga eléctrica es
conservativa siempre se conserva para
cada proceso en otras palabras la carga
total inicial va a ser igual a la carga
total final después de cualquier proceso
y que hagamos un problema que involucre
a la carga eléctrica
esferas de metal del mismo tamaño
comienzan con las cargas que se muestran
a continuación así que aquí la tenemos
la esfera x comienza con una carga de 5
con la esfera y james empieza con una
carga de 3 cook y la esfera zeta empieza
con una carga de menos 2 q
si tocas la esfera x con la esfera y
después las separadas y a continuación
tocas la esfera y james con la esfera
zeta después las separadas cuál será la
carga final de cada esfera bien primero
si tocamos la esfera x con la esfera
james entonces qué es lo que va a pasar
bueno observar lo siguiente hay una
carga total de 8 q entre ellas y ya que
son de tamaño idéntico ambas van a
compartir la carga total lo que
significa que después de tocarse están
tendrá una carga de 4 un positivo y esta
también va a tener una carga de 4
positivo eso porque las dos son del
mismo tamaño si una de las esferas fuera
más grande que la otra ganaría más la
carga pero al final la carga total sigue
conservándose y si después tocas
esfera james con la esfera zeta que es
lo que va a pasar
bueno aquí tenemos cuatro cum y aquí hay
menos dos q y como van a compartir la
carga por igual entonces ésta va a
quedar con una carga de cum de q
positiva y ésta también va a quedar con
una carga de positiva así que si
observamos las respuestas
vemos que la se cumple eso carga
supuestas atraen y cargas iguales se
repelen y lo que la ley de coloma hace
es darte una manera para encontrar la
magnitud de la fuerza eléctrica entre
dos cargas y la fórmula para ver esta
fuerza va a ser la siguiente lo que nos
dice la ley de coulón es que la magnitud
de la fuerza eléctrica que se ejerce
entre dos cargas va a ser igual a camps
que es una constante la cual es igual a
9 por 10 a 9 newtons metros cuadrados
entre colomos cuadrados ya esto habrá
que multiplicarlo por el producto de m
dos cargas de estas dos cargas las
cuales van a ser medidas en colomos
nkoulou y esto será dividido por la
distancia que hay de centro al centro de
las dos cargas elevada al cuadrado y ojo
no olvides elevar esta distancia al
cuadrado
de hecho esta distancia se debe de dar
en metros si quieres encontrar las
unidades en el sistema internacional de
newtons para la fuerza además una cosa
que es importante es que esta fórmula de
aquí no se basa en los signos negativos
o positivos que tengan las cargas para
decirte en qué dirección apuntan las
fuerzas porque sólo se usa el hecho de
que las cargas opuestas atraen y que las
cargas iguales se repelen y usamos la
ley de coulón para obtener la magnitud
de la fuerza ahora vamos a hacer un
problema que involucra a la ley de colom
o dos cargas ejercen una sobre la otra
una fuerza eléctrica de magnitud f
cuál será la magnitud de la nueva fuerza
si tomamos el triple de la distancia
entre ellas y el doble de la magnitud de
una de las cargas bien así que primero
vamos a recordar qué es lo que nos dice
la ley de colom la ley de colom nos dice
que la fuerza entre dos cargas
eléctricas va a ser igual a la constante
camps que multiplica a q1 por q 2 muy
bien esto dividido entre la distancia al
cuadrado esto dividido entre la
distancia elevada al cuadrado y ahora si
queremos encontrar la fuerza nueva la
fuerza nueva ésta va a ser igual a bueno
la constante camps que multiplican a q1
y ahora lo que voy a hacer es duplicar
una de las fuerzas así que lo voy a
poner así 2 que multiplica a q2 ya esto
lo voy a dividir en tres y ahora vamos a
fijarnos en el triple de la distancia
entre ellas de la distancia original
y bueno a esto hay que elevarlo al
cuadrado
ahora si observas por aquí tenemos un
factor de 2 y por acá abajo tenemos un
factor de 3 elevado al cuadrado ojo este
3 lo vamos a elevar al cuadrado por lo
tanto vamos a tener un factor de dos
novenos de dos novenos que multiplica
quien bueno multiplican acá que
multiplica su vez a q1 que multiplica a
su vez a q2 ya esto lo tenemos dividido
entre la distancia elevado al cuadrado
pero si observas esta cantidad que tengo
aquí esto que tengo aquí es exactamente
lo mismo que la fuerza original así que
la magnitud de la nueva fuerza va a ser
lo mismo que la magnitud de la fuerza
anterior multiplicado por un factor de
dos novenos eso nos da esta respuesta
avn
la corriente eléctrica y nos dice la
cantidad de colones de carga que pasan
por un punto en un segundo dado así que
si observas en un punto en el cable y
cuentas cuántos colom se están pasando
por este cable en ese segundo eso sería
la corriente eléctrica y si queremos ver
esto como una fórmula podemos ver que la
corriente eléctrica es lo mismo que la
carga que pasan por el punto pm en un
tiempo t y estos nos dan unidades de
coulón entre segundos y lo podemos
abreviar como amper y ya que la carga y
el tiempo no son vectores entonces la
corriente eléctrica no es un vector y
algo que es un poco extraño es la
dirección convencional de la corriente
esta es la dirección en la que fluye la
carga positiva sin embargo las cargas
positivas no fluyen en un cable las
únicas cargas que realmente fluyen son
las cargas negativas estas de aquí
entonces si decimos que las cargas
eléctricas negativas están fluyendo si
la izquierda
es físicamente lo mismo que las cargas
positivas fluyan hacia la derecha así
que en la mayoría de los problemas de
física pretendemos como si fueran las
cargas positivas las que se mueven sin
embargo son realmente los electrones que
son negativos los que se están moviendo
dentro del cable y si te preguntas cómo
se ve un problema de la corriente
eléctrica
ahora vamos a resolver uno una corriente
de 3 amperes fluye en un cierto circuito
cuánta carga pasa por un cierto punto en
un circuito en un lapso de 5 minutos
así que recordemos la corriente
eléctrica la acabamos de definir como la
cantidad de carga que pasa en un tiempo
dado muy bien pero ya tenemos la
corriente eléctrica así que si queremos
despejar de que la carga nos va a quedar
que la carga es lo mismo que la
corriente eléctrica que multiplica al
tiempo muy bien así que en este caso la
carga va a ser igual a la corriente
eléctrica que es lo mismo que 3 amperes
3 amperes
y multiplican al tiempo pero ojo el
tiempo no lo podemos dar en minutos lo
tenemos que dar en segundos para así
obtener con la oms entonces voy a tener
cinco minutos minutos que multiplican a
60 segundos esto por cada minuto y bueno
a cuánto va a ser igual
todo esto esto va a ser igual a 900 900
go la oms esta es mi respuesta que es la
de la resistencia miden que tanto supone
un resistor o una resistencia al flujo
de la corriente eléctrica eso quiere
decir que entre más grande sea la
resistencia o el registro menor
corriente dejará fluir y la definición
de resistencia se basa en la ley d
la ley de ohm dice que la cantidad de
corriente eléctrica es proporcional al
voltaje y es inversamente proporcional a
la resistencia así que entre estos dos
puntos que tengo aquí la corriente que
va a fluir va a ser igual al voltaje
entre la resistencia que hay entre esos
dos puntos así que entre mayor sea la
resistencia menor corriente eléctrica va
a ser la que fluya y entre más voltaje
tengas mayor corriente eléctrica va a
ser la que tengamos y esto es lo que nos
dice la ley de ohm incluso la ley de ohm
te puede dar una forma de definir la
resistencia pero también puedes
determinar la resistencia de un elemento
de un circuito de un resistor conociendo
el tamaño y la forma de ese resistor en
otras palabras la resistencia de este
resistor va a ser igual a esta rom
la resistividad y esta resistividad es
una resistencia natural que tienen a la
corriente esto multiplicado por el largo
de este resistor es decir entre más
largo sea este resistor mayor
resistencia vas a tener y entre más
corto sea este resistor menor
resistencia vas a tener y esto dividido
entre el área del resistor la cual es
esta sección transversal que tenemos
aquí y bueno la corriente puede estar
fluyendo dentro o fuera de este resistor
y si el rexistro es un cilindro entonces
el área de este círculo va a ser por el
radio elevado al cuadrado y las unidades
de la resistencia son los oms esto que
tenemos aquí y bueno no es un vector de
hecho la resistencia siempre va a ser
positiva o en su dado caso 0 y como se
ve un problema que involucre la ley de
ohm o en su dado caso la resistencia de
un resistor cilindro
bueno veamos el siguiente problema
cuando una batería de voltaje bm se
conecta a un resistor cilíndrico simple
de longitud l y de radio r fluye una
corriente eléctrica
a través de la batería cuál es la
resistividad del resistor y ojo la
resistividad rom del resistor bueno para
eso primero vamos a usar la ley de ohm y
la ley de ohm dice que la intensidad de
corriente eléctrica es igual al cambio
en el voltaje entre la resistencia y si
de aquí despejamos la resistencia vamos
a obtener que la resistencia es
exactamente lo mismo que el cambio en el
voltaje esto dividido a su vez entre la
corriente eléctrica pero por otra parte
acabamos de ver que la resistencia
un resistor cilíndrico es lo mismo que
el ron que es la resistividad que
multiplica al largo de este resistor
entre el área transversal muy bien y si
ahora utilizo esto para ponerlo justo
aquí me va a quedar lo siguiente me va a
quedar que rom que multiplica al largo
esto dividido entre el ancho me va a ser
igual al cambio en el voltaje entre la
intensidad de corriente eléctrica ahora
de aquí podemos despejar la roma rom va
a ser igual a el voltaje por el área
transversal esto dividido a su vez por
la corriente eléctrica por el largo la
corriente eléctrica por el largo pero
sabemos que el área
un resistor cilíndrico va a ser igual a
pin por el radio elevado al cuadrado así
que voy a utilizar esta información de
aquí para meterlo justo acá y entonces
me va a quedar que ro es decir la
resistividad va a ser igual al voltaje
que multiplica a pin que multiplica al
radio elevado al cuadrado
todo esto dividido entre la corriente
eléctrica que multiplica a l y si
observas es justo la respuesta hace
ahora bien cuando tratamos con circuitos
complicados con mucho resistor es muchas
veces debe reducir esos resistor es a
una menor cantidad de resistor es que
sea equivalente y las dos maneras que
haces esto es encontrando resistor es
que estén en serie o resistor es que
estén en paralelo ahora bien si hablamos
de resistor es que están en serie estos
van a tener la misma corriente eléctrica
a la misma corriente eléctrica que fluye
por ellos si la corriente eléctrica se
ramificará se ramificará algo más o
menos así entonces no estaríamos
hablando de resistor es en serie si
estamos hablando de resistor es en serie
lo que quiero que veas es que el
resistor equivalente va a ser igual a la
suma de los otros dos resistor es así
que la corriente para resistor es en
serie es la misma pero el voltaje podría
ser distinto porque tenemos diferentes
resistencias ahora bien si hablamos de
resistor es que están en paralelo
entonces la corriente va a entrar y
después se va a dividir para cada uno de
los receptores para este registro y para
este resistor y después la corriente se
vuelve a unir en este punto para seguir
a cualquier otra cosa del circuito y si
este es el caso puedes encontrar la
resistencia equivalente entre estos dos
puntos entre este punto de kim y este
punto de camps o dicho otra manera entre
esta porción de él
entre esta porción del circuito vas a
encontrar esta resistencia equivalente
simplemente sumando 1 entre la primera
resistencia más 1 entre la segunda
resistencia pero ten cuidado 1 entre la
resistencia 1 más 1 entre la resistencia
2 te va a dar 1 entre la resistencia
equivalente si quieres obtener la
resistencia equivalente vas a tener que
tomar de recíproco de esto o tomarte la
división de 1 entre esta cantidad que
tengo aquí ahora bien trabajamos con un
problema que tenga que ver con
resistencias en serie o en paralelo
considera el circuito que se muestra a
continuación y tenemos este circuito de
aquí cuál es la corriente eléctrica que
fluye a través de la resistencia de 8
oms ok y bueno puedes estar tentado a
tomarte la ley de ohm y decir la
intensidad de corriente eléctrica es
igual al cambio en el voltaje está
dividido entre la resistencia y ya
porque el voltaje es 24 volts ya esto lo
voy a dividir entre la resistencia que
son 8 oms y bueno esto me va a dar 3
amperes y ya está pero qué creés esto no
está del todo bien porque lo que dice la
ley de ohm es que la intensidad de
corriente eléctrica que vamos a aplicar
a un cierto resistor va a ser igual al
voltaje que llega a ese resistor entre
la resistencia que tiene así que si
introducimos este resistor de ocho oms
habrá que fijarnos en cuál es el voltaje
que le llega porque ojo no va a ser este
voltaje de 24 volts completos en otras
palabras la batería provee un voltaje
entre este punto y este punto que tengo
aquí porque también va a haber una caída
de voltaje a través de las resistencias
de m6 oms y 12 oms por lo tanto la
cantidad de voltaje que va a llegar a 8
oms es menor
así que qué te parece si reducimos estas
resistencias a una sola resistencia lo
primero que vamos a explicarnos en estas
dos resistencias que si observas están
en paralelo aquí se divide la intensidad
de corriente eléctrica y después llega
de nuevo a este punto de aquí entonces
como estas dos están en paralelo voy a
decir que 1 entre esta resistencia que
estoy buscando estas dos va a ser igual
a 1 entre 6 más 1 entre 12 y esto va a
ser igual a bueno un sexto más un
doceavo son 3 doceavos que es lo mismo
que un cuarto o dicho de otra manera
estas dos resistencias las puede reducir
en esta resistencia de color verde que
es de 4
así que entre este punto de aquí y este
punto de que tenemos una resistencia de
cuatro ojos observa que esta resistencia
que tengo aquí está en serie con esta
otra resistencia por lo tanto la
resistencia total va a ser igual a la
suma de 8 oms más estos cuatro outs por
lo tanto esto va a ser igual a bueno 8 4
son 12 oms
esa es la resistencia total de este
circuito que tengo aquí así que ahora
puedo decir que todo este circuito de
aquí se puede reducir a un circuito que
tiene solamente una resistencia de 12 ó
12 oms y bueno teníamos un voltaje de 24
volts y ahora si puedo quitar esta parte
de aquí y este resultado que no está
bien y la corriente que fluye a través
de esta batería lo cual va a ser bueno
la división de esto que es 2 amperes y
si observas este resistor de 8 oms está
en serie con esta batería por lo tanto
tienen la misma intensidad de corriente
los elementos de un circuito muchas
veces usan potencia eléctrica es decir
cuando la corriente eléctrica fluye a
través de un resistor los electrones
cambian su energía potencial
electrostática a otros tipos de energía
como calor luz y sonido
la tasa a la cual los electrones cambian
su energía a otra forma de energía es lo
que se conoce como potencia eléctrica
así que la tasa en la cual un resistor
está convirtiendo energía eléctrica en
calor es la potencia eléctrica utilizada
por esa resistencia en otras palabras a
la cantidad de energía que fluye en un
cierto tiempo a esto le llamamos
potencia recuerdas pero ahora podemos
ver esta misma potencia a este número de
jules por segundo en términos de
cantidades como la corriente eléctrica
el voltaje y la resistencia así que la
potencia utilizada por un resistor lo
podemos escribir de la siguiente manera
en una primera forma de escribirlo como
la corriente eléctrica que multiplica al
voltaje pero si usamos la ley de ohm y
sustituimos este valor de aquí podemos
encontrarnos con que la potencia
eléctrica es igual a la corriente
eléctrica elevada al cuadrado por la
resistencia del resistor
bueno también podemos reorganizar estas
fórmulas para obtener que la potencia es
igual a el voltaje elevado al cuadrado
dividido entre la resistencia del
resistor es decir estas tres te deben de
dar la misma potencia si las utilizas de
manera correcta y si quieres determinar
el número de jules de energía que da esa
potencia bueno recuerda que esto es lo
mismo que la energía dividido entre el
tiempo de aquí podrías despejará la
energía ahora bien las unidades de la
potencia eléctrica son las mismas
unidades que tienes en la potencia los
watts o el 'you'll de entre segundo y
bueno la potencia eléctrica no es un
vector así que si te preguntas cómo se
ve en un problema que tiene que ver con
potencia eléctrica podemos resolver el
siguiente dicen un foco de resistencia r
se conecta a una fuente de voltaje en un
segundo foco de resistencia 12 m se
conecta a otra fuente de voltaje 2 b
se está duplicando la resistencia y el
voltaje como podemos comparar el
potencial generado por el segundo foco
en comparación con el potencial generado
por el primer foco y bueno ya que
tenemos la información de la resistencia
y el voltaje vamos a utilizar la fórmula
para la potencia eléctrica que dice que
la potencia eléctrica es igual a la
diferencia en el voltaje esto elevado al
cuadrado y dividido entre r que en el
caso del primer foco esto va a ser igual
al voltaje elevado al cuadrado dividido
entre r hasta aquí vamos bien pero a
nuestro segundo foco le va a pasar lo
siguiente vamos a agarrar el voltaje y
lo vamos a duplicar así que tenemos dos
veces este mismo voltaje este mismo
voltaje déjame cerrar esto y lo voy a
elevar al cuadrado y también dicen que
tenemos el doble de la resistencia que
teníamos en el foco original así que me
voy a tomar
dos veces la resistencia que teníamos
inicialmente
y bueno si le vas a esto al cuadrado me
va a quedar esto es lo mismo que cuatro
veces de cuadrada de cuadrada ok esto
dividido su vez entre bueno 22 veces
ahora observamos que nuestros factores
cuatro medios que es lo mismo que 2 esto
es exactamente lo mismo que 2 que
multiplican am b cuadrado entre r pero
esto de aquí esto de aquí era la
potencia eléctrica que teníamos
originalmente era esto de aquí por lo
tanto el segundo foco va a tener un
factor de 2 en la potencia eléctrica eso
quiere decir que el foco con
resistencias 2 r tienen el doble de
potencial estamos hablando del inciso a
y eso significa que el foco va a ser más
brillante la cantidad que determina el
brillo del foco es la potencia eléctrica
de ese foco no es necesariamente la
resistencia o el voltaje es la
combinación de los dos en esta fórmula
esta fórmula con la que empezamos o en
las otras fórmulas podemos obtener la
potencia eléctrica de cada foco por lo
tanto la potencia eléctrica te va a
indicar el brillo del foco dos ideas muy
útiles son las leyes
de hip hop y la primera es la ley de
nodos y dice toda la corriente que entra
a un nodo es igual a toda la corriente
que sale del nodo y lo puedes ver aquí
toda la corriente que entra es igual a
toda la corriente que sale y es que
estos se basan en el principio de la
conservación de la carga en otras
palabras si sumas toda la corriente que
fluye en uno doble está debe ser igual a
toda la corriente que sale del nodo
porque la carga se conserva así que la
carga no puede ser creada ni destruida
en cualquier punto del circuito de igual
manera que el agua no puede ser creada
ni destruida dentro de una serie de
tuberías y la segunda ley es la ley de
lazos dicen si sumas todas las cargas
del potencial eléctrico el voltaje en un
lazo cerrado de un circuito eléctrico
el resultado será igual a cero y bueno
esta ley se basa en el principio de la
conservación de la energía y lo puedes
ver aquí así que si sumas todos los
voltajes encontrados a través de un lazo
cerrado a través del circuito siempre
sumar a cero
los electrones van a ganar energía y van
a perder energía cuando entren en una
resistencia sin embargo la cantidad
total de energía que ganan en la batería
debe de ser igual a la cantidad total de
energía que pierden debido a las
resistencias en otras palabras si
consideramos un circuito complicado que
tengan una batería y tres resistencias
entonces la corriente total fluyendo en
un nodo por ejemplo aquí tenemos el nodo
y uno debe de ser igual a la corriente
total saliendo de este nodo es decir y 2
e iu 3 ya que ninguna carga es creada
destruida y eso significa que cuando
estas dos corrientes se combinan de
nuevo justo aquí y se combinan de nuevo
la corriente total fluyendo fuera de
esta sección será de nuevo y uno por
aquí tenemos que pasar la corriente
y si seguimos un nodo cercano a través
de este circuito la suma de todos los
voltajes debe de ser igual a 0 es decir
el voltaje de la batería menos el
voltaje del primer registro menos el
voltaje del segundo resistor esto nos
tiene que dar igual a cero así que si te
preguntas cómo se ve un problema que
involucre el lo que estamos aprendiendo
con las leyes de kirchoff podemos ver el
siguiente problema dicen considera el
circuito que se muestra a continuación
cuál es el voltaje a través de la
resistencia de 6 oms para esto voy a
usar la ley de lazos así que si
empezamos detrás de esta batería y
hacemos un lazo que atrapen esta
resistencia de la cual queremos saber su
voltaje entonces me va a quedar algo más
o menos así este va a ser mi lazo y
bueno recuerda que lo que queremos es el
voltaje de esta resistencia de 6 oms
ahora también sabemos que si sumamos
todos los voltajes a través de este lazo
debe de ser igual a cero déjame anotarlo
la suma de todos los voltajes que hay en
este lazo tiene que ser igual a cero así
que si nos fijamos empezamos con un
voltaje de 24 volts un voltaje de 24
volts esto es lo que nos da la batería
ya esto le voy a quitar primero el
voltaje que hay en estos 6 oms ok y
también le voy a quitar el voltaje que
hay en esta otra resistencia de 82 ahora
lo padre de esto es que podemos calcular
cuál es el voltaje que pasa por esta
resistencia de 8 oms porque sabemos que
por ella pasan 2 amperes entonces sí
recuerdo que el voltaje es igual a la
corriente que multiplica a la
resistencia esto por la ley de ohm
entonces puedo decir que el voltaje en
esta resistencia de 8 oms va a ser igual
a 2 amperes que multiplican a 8
y bueno esto me dan 16 volts entonces
ahora que tengo esta cantidad ya puedo
utilizarla en mi problema voy a tratar
esto de aquí y lo voy a prender justo
acá y entonces me va a quedar que 24
volts 24 volts menos este voltaje en la
resistencia que estamos buscando el
voltaje en la resistencia de 6 oms -
menos 16 volts esto tiene que ser igual
a 0 o dicho de otra manera si despejamos
este voltaje el voltaje de la
resistencia de 6 oms va a ser lo mismo
que 24 volts menos 16 volts lo cual es
igual a 8
de lujo ya puedo decir que mi respuesta
es la ve y ojo ya que la resistencia de
12 oms y la de 6 oms están en paralelo
el voltaje a través de la resistencia de
12 oms también va a ser de 8 volts así
que este voltaje también va a ser de 8
volts el voltaje a través de cualquiera
de dos elementos en paralelo tiene que
ser el mismo
-los voltímetros son dispositivos que
miden el voltaje entre dos puntos los
voltímetros deben estar conectados en
paralelo en paralelo con los dos puntos
así el volt y metro puede medir el
voltaje de manera correcta en otras
palabras para medir el voltaje de r3 lo
que vamos a hacer es conectar los dos
puntos del voltímetro justo aquí esto
nos dará el voltaje a través de r3 y
bueno el multímetro observa que está
conectado
paralelo está conectado en paralelo por
otra parte los perímetros son
dispositivos que emiten la corriente que
pasan a través de un punto en un
circuito los amperímetro deben de estar
conectados en serie en serie con los dos
puntos a medir así la corriente puede
fluir de manera adecuada a través del
amperímetro así que si queremos medir
cuánta corriente fluye a través de r1
tenemos que conectar a este amperímetro
amd en serie con r 1 noten que para que
estos aparatos funcionen bien los
amperímetro deben de tener una
resistencia interna de casi 0 y esto es
porque de este modo no van a afectar a
la corriente que fluye a través del
circuito y por otra parte los
voltímetros deben de tener una
resistencia interna casi infinita así no
igualarían ninguna de las corrientes de
la resistencia que estén pasando por
ellos en realidad los amperímetro tienen
una resistencia interna muy pequeña pero
distinta de cero y los multímetros
tienen una resistencia muy alta
pero no infinita y bueno si te preguntas
cómo se ve un problema que involucra
amperímetro si voltímetros podemos ver
el siguiente considera el circuito que
se muestra a continuación este de aquí
si los círculos numerados son
voltímetros multímetros cuáles de ellos
nos dan el voltaje correcto que pasan a
través del registro de 8 ohms
seleccionan las dos respuestas correctas
y deben ser cuidadosos porque algunos
problemas de apem van a requerir la
selección de dos respuestas correctas
cuando tenemos una opción múltiple así
que asegúrate de leer cuidadosamente las
instrucciones bien lo primero que veo es
que el voltímetro 4 es una terrible
opción nunca conectes tu volt y metro en
serie con el elemento al cual quieres
medir tu voltaje así que esta no es la
opción correcta ahora si me fijo en el
número uno en este de aquí y observa que
estoy midiendo el voltaje entre dos
puntos donde adentro no hay nada
solamente cable
de estos dos puntos así que el voltaje
medido por el voltímetro número uno va a
ser exactamente igual que es cero ya que
el voltaje a través de un cable de
resistencia a cero debe darte cero volts
por lo tanto la opción correcta no es la
1 así que puedo tachar también está y
bueno las opciones correctas van a ser
el número 2 y el número 3 el número 2
del voltaje a través de la resistencia
de 811 observamos que la resistencia de
8 oms está adentro de estos dos puntos y
también el voltímetro 3 porque si
observas esta resistencia de 8 oms
también está dentro de estos 2 puntos